[Musique]
il
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le site
de la fnac et sur ma chaîne youtube
également je suis monsieur heureux je
suis accompagné de julien doit bas qui
est chef produit chez samsung tout à
fait comment vas tu ça va être en rien
très bien très heureux de te vois alors
on est ensemble pour à peu près 45
minutes de live ouais c'est à peu près
ça et on va venir parler des nouveautés
de cinq secondes alors je sais pas si
vous avez suivi c'est compliqué de ne
pas l'avoir vu c'est ça le sont via
beaucoup de nouveautés sont là des
smartphones qui se plie entre autres de
format tout à fait un galaxy z flip 300
vrai et le galaxy cette folle de trois
on en parlera de thaler hyper canon en
plus on a du style et ça vient d'arriver
c'est beau c'est nouveau vous allez voir
ça et de l'amour connectée également il
ya deux mondes connectés des deux mondes
connectés alors on va se parler des
et donc des nouvelles ou ocz 4 way road
quatre classiques et ocz 4 watts kto est
à tous quoi votre ex et ça c'est
vachement bien qu' on parlera également
de dio un petit peu vous allez voir
c'est intéressant d'aller buzz 2 qui
vient d'arriver galaxie buzz donc tout
un programme ça va nous occuper pendant
45 minutes et puis également il ya des
codes promo c'est intéressant si vous
voulez acheter l'un de ses produits l'un
est le temps on pouvait regarder c'est
super bien marianne2 code je vous les
donne tout de suite le premier code
c'est samsung 50 selon permet d'avoir 50
euros de remise sur la wild cat valable
jusqu'au 12 septembre et puis samsung
sens c'est dans le chat un sens la
chaîne youtube si vous allez voir les
les codes c'est moins 100 euros
directement sur les samsung galaxy z
flip et z folle de 3 pour paris via
détroit à chaque fois ça c'est valable
jusqu'au 15 septembre tout à fait et
alors en plus de ça et c'est cumulable
avec les offres que tu viens de citer
donc chez samsung on a plusieurs offres
et notamment sur les galaxies watch
quatre avec 50 euros de google paye
credit offert et 50 euros de bonus
reprise donc si vous ramenez votre
ancien monde connecté vous bénéficiez de
50 euros de bonus reprises en plus de la
valeur résiduelle de la mode connecté
que vous ramenez et pour tout achat côté
smartphones cette fois ci d'un galaxy z
flip 3 ou d'un galaxy est folle de 3
vous avez 150 euros
d'accessoires enfin 150 euros offerts
sur une sélection d'accessoires ça vous
permet de vous et de vous offrir les
galaxy 2 2 ou 1 espen 1 espagne par
exemple ce qui est pas mal du tout et
notamment sur le puits d'ailleurs pas eu
notamment que sur les épaules de trois
on en parle de quelques instants vous
allez voir ce espagne du louvre de
nouveaux horizons à ce produit c'est
super intéressant mais ça on garde
encore un peu le suspense on en parle
dans quelques instants et puis bien
évidemment toutes vos questions
questions vous pouvez poser directement
sur le site de la fnac vous pouvez y
aller on vous répondra appuie aussi sur
la chaîne youtube l'algérie le tchad
sous les yeux un jeu vous voir vous êtes
là vous êtes nombreux nombreuses merci à
vous êtes là et puis n'hésitez pas à
poser vos questions et on vous répondra
directement enfin surtout julien salut
experts mais moi je me ferai un plaisir
de retranscrire de retranscrire les
questions alors on a commencé tout de
suite avec de la montre avec la montre
tout à fait toi tu as la warcraft moi
j'ai la watch quatre tout court moi je
l'adoré 24 tout à fait la classique et
toi tu as la classique à chacun et la
paire comme c'est ça absolument bravo
chacun son truc quoi maintenant qu'est
ce qu'elle raconte en fait c'est bon je
me parlait juste avant qu'on rentre donc
et on l'attendait depuis quelques temps
et il ya une vraie nouveauté grosses
nouveautés logicielles vous travaillez
avec google en collaborant ils sont à
droite pour avoir webos qui est
l'expérience de google directement dans
votre monde qui vient d'arriver tu peux
vous raconter ce qui se passe ouais
alors nous l'idée en fait dans cette
idée de que la monde connecté finalement
la prolongation parfaite du smartphone
bas bien sûr l'idée c'était de proposer
une expérience qui soit finalement la
plus proche possible de ce que tu peux
de ce que vous pouvez retrouver
aujourd'hui sur un smartphone galaxy et
c'est pour ça qu'on est venu travailler
avec google pour refondre et refaire
complètement l'interface logicielle que
tu peux trouver donc dans la galaxie
watch 4 et dans la galaxie hôte 4
classique puisque il ya toute la
puissance de tyson que tu pouvais
retrouver jusqu'à jusqu'à l'année
dernière sur sur nos mondes connectés et
la puissance de google surtout l'aspect
logiciel également ce qui fait qu'il ya
énormément de nouveautés tu retrouves un
petit peu toutes les applications
compatibles avec les watch directement
sur directement sur tellement de
connecter la loupe les stores taipei
store est calme énorme catalogue
d'applications exactement exactement et
avec l'énorme catalogue d'applications
qu'on connaît et à partir de là monde
forcément tu pourras battu pourra
télécharger les applications tu
souhaites je suis vachement bien donc là
j'ai beaucoup d'application et tu peux
montrer rapidement qu'est ce que je peux
venir faire question d'une nouveauté
phare comporterait dans cette montre est
alors au bas pour ne citer que cette
application peut on peut se parler de
google maps alors je sais pas si la
planète est ce que est ce qu'on peut la
voir juste là ça serait super on peut se
parler de google maps est donc en fin de
compte on a une interface google maps
directement sur bas sur sa monde
connecté ça ne les évite en fin de
compte de prendre son smartphone à
chaque fois pour pouvoir se repérer
quand tu es en train de te ballader
exactement livret est donc là du coup tu
mets l'adresse que tu souhaites
renseigner tu peux même la renseigner de
manière vocale donc ça c'est donc ça
c'est très sympa et une fois que une
fois que s'est renseigné bata juste à
lever ton poignet pour te diriger et
c'est quand même bien plus sympa que de
devoir à chaque fois sortir son
smartphone ou de garder le smartphone à
la main
à chaque fois que tu te déplaces donc
c'est très très cool ça c'est très très
cool ça veut dire que tu as
effectivement ça sous les yeux tu peux
voir et après côté un peu malin on parle
des buzz dans quelques instants tu peux
avoir des bugs et tu peux avoir la voix
de google qui t'a dit tourner à droite
exactement cinquante mètres tu dis
attendre ce que je suis en droit je
vérifie et ça c'est vachement maintenant
six ans libre en fête what a exactement
tu as les mains libres et puis tu
parlais de finalement de synergie qui
peut exister avec avec les écouteurs de
chez samsung donc les galaxies bottes
boots deux pour ne citer qu'eux tu peux
aussi contrôler et à musique par exemple
avec sept mondes connectés cité sur
spotify sur deezer ou ou sur une autre
application de streaming musical tu peux
tout à fait contrôler ta musique
directement directement bien ta montre
pour passer au morceau suivant passer au
morceau précédent m sur play il met sur
pause etc etc ça c'est génial alors il
ya plein de nouvelles choses et
notamment ça ça m'intéresse l'analyse de
masse corporelle de la composition
corporelle donc je peux avoir mon imc
cependant plein d'infos qui tu peux nous
expliquer ce qui se passait en fait ça
vient je peux dire remplacer mais
presque après une balance connectée
alors c'est l'idée c'est l'idée c'est
que alors la moutte ne peut pas encore
pesé
marché
on recommande aux utilisateurs de ne pas
match de ne pas marcher sur le monde
connecté
toutefois cela dix sept montres elle va
venir analyser tout tout votre
composition corporelle donc très
simplement vous venez poser en fin de
compte vous vos 2 doit donc votre majeur
et votre annulaire sur les deux boutons
latéraux et en fin de compte vous avez
un faible courant électrique qui passe
dans votre corps et qui va permettre qui
va permettre d'analyser vos données
corporelles en profondeur donc on se
parle de de masse squelettiques on se
parle dit mc on se parle de masse
graisseuse on se parle de toutes ces
dates a key qui finalement peuvent vous
est donné habituellement par une balance
connectée alors tu parles de courant
électrique qui passe on n'est pas écrite
et non sans rien soyez tranquilles je
suis complètement transparent mais
effectivement c'est super bien et ça
permet vraiment de mesurer sa absolument
ça permet de mesurer tous ces
indicateurs pour alors c'était c'était
une vraie demande aussi de beaucoup
d'utilisateurs pour essayer de suivre au
quotidien un petit peu les efforts qu'on
peut faire côté alimentation côté sport
et c'est pour avoir des indicatifs plus
précis sur bas sur sur notre composition
corporelle et on est les seuls à le
faire cette galaxie série galaxy ou ocz
permettre permettre d'indiquer un petit
peu toutes ses métriques de composition
corporelle compte tout de suite bien sûr
au quotidien on recommande enfin de
compte de le faire au réveil le matin
mais pour bat pour avoir toujours la
même routine au même moment exactement
tout à fait le même c'est ce que je fais
quand je joue sur ma balance pour battre
yb sur la balance je mets les doigts
mais si je me masse il faut toujours la
balance exactement on peut également
mesuré le taux d'oxygène dans le sang tu
peux mettre nos son bien-être qui est
vraiment mise en avant avec sept
contrôleurs tout à fait on reste sur une
monde connecté qui est capable en fin de
compte 2 ben de finalement suivre ton
sport on a un côté bien être et sports
qui a évidemment mis en avant et
on peut faire des électrocardiogrammes
on peut évidemment de mesurer sa
fréquence cardiaque un petit peu en
temps réel quand tu le souhaites mesurer
le nombre de calories que tu brûles au
quotidien fixé un nombre de packs tu as
envie envie de faire de manière
journalière et le natif des objectifs
tout à fait donc on va sur une monde
connecté qui est capable de traquer ton
activité physique de manière hyper
efficace très précises puisque on a une
puce gps qui est qui est directement
intégré dans la montre et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui nous permet de nous
bat de précisément de géolocaliser quand
on est en train de se balader avec
google maps donc tout ça c'est possible
et et c'est très très cool alors tu sais
que moyen au sujet de discorde chez moi
c'est ma femme dit que je ronfle et moi
je vous dis non je suis allé je gonfle
elle elle peut le dire emma est tranché
le débat pour avoir enfin la paix à la
maison quand c'est important donc
j'espère que ça va aller de mon côté
j'ai pas encore regardé j'ai un peu peur
mais tu as tout chef gestion du sommeil
qui est extrêmement important dans le
monde parle de bien-être et souvent
quand on parle de bien-être on pense aux
phases éveillé et on pense pas aux
phases tournant dormir là tout à fait
mal et elle l'a montré capable
d'analyser un petit peu tes différentes
phases de les différentes phases de
sommeil par lesquels tu passes
pour juste fournir des analyses
détaillées sur quand est-ce que tu as un
sommeil profond etc etc et effectivement
ça détecte sa détecte les ronflements
donc tu ne peut plus nier devant ta ça
n'existe pas
voilà vous ne pouvez plus nier que que
vous ronflez face à votre conjoint votre
compte puisque la montre est capable
effectivement de calais afin de
détecter effectivement vos ronflements
laquelle moment de la nuit et c'est
exactement
alors il ya deux modèles différents on à
la watch 4 et la wave classic est ce que
tu peux nous on peut les voir à la
caméra pour vraiment montrer les
différences c'est il ya un truc est
significatif pour que j'aime beaucoup
c'est que sur la classique tu va le
montrer sommes donc là on allait watch 4
on a les 24 hockey qui sont qui ont des
bracelets qui peut voir des brassées ans
icône alors les bracelets sont
interchangeables sont des brasses les
standards qui sont disponibles en 40 mm
juste là et en 44 mm juste ici et nous
avons les ouates quatre classiques qui
elles reprennent un petit peu plus les
codes de l'horlogerie traditionnelle
auquel elle dispose d'une couronne
rotative physique que vous voyez juste
ici autour des autour des cadrans alors
que les moins de 4 dispose d'une
couronne rotatif qui elle est et digital
est tactile en fait là on la fait
tourner et alors il ya un côté qui est
hyper sympa et très satisfaisante et
sont intéressantes et que ça tourne sous
le doigt et moi je pourrais jouer
désormais c'est assez addictif c'est ça
ce n est pas le premier à la meilleure
voyez là je passe des heures à tourner
et donc ici tu de manière tactile tout
bascule sur sur les différents menus de
sur les différents menus de la montre
donc c'est en fait très sympa et gagnent
c'est ça en fait ça tu fais juste avec
ton doigt hop là que je me mette plein
au centre tu fais avec ton doigt comme
ça l'un ouais tout à fait je suis pas un
pro de salle à manger vraiment l'autre
on regarde les intéresse pas champion
j'avais les mains voilà donc on peut
voir le patient doit la caméra si si
viens je viens ici
est donc là on a une couronne qui est
qui pour le coup est tactile là où
effectivement sur la boîte 4 classique
vous avez une couronne qui vous avez une
couronne qui rotatives et qui reprend
les codes de l'horlogerie un petit peu
plus traditionnel donc y en a vraiment
pour tous les goûts
pour avec des bracelets de différentes
couleurs des bracelets de différentes
compositions tu as des bracelets en cuir
tu as des bracelets en silicone donc
donc très sain ok donc ça c'est top donc
de montres les bras de modèles
différents les bracelets gagne
évidemment plusieurs tailles vous invite
à aller jeter un petit coup d'oeil sur
le terrain sur le site de la fnac comme
ça vous saurez tout et vous verrez tout
et c'est plutôt bien une fois de plus
vous dit le code samsung 50 et puis le
tarif tarifs parce qu'on les hait l'état
les deux se montre on les a les tarifs
de ces montres alors
on est sur un prix d'entrée à 269 euros
sur la galaxie votre 4 que vous voyez
sur juste là
ici ici magnifique la galaxie watch
quatre donc en 40 mm 50 euros de plus
pour la version 44 mm ouais donc 319 et
quand on bascule sur la boîte câble
classique on est à 3 169 euros en prix
d'appel sur la version 42 mm et 419 sur
la version 46 mm elles sont disponibles
en bluetooth ou en cas de gel exactement
et ça c'est beau et ça me plaît on va
continuer parce que alors on a
effectivement ces montres qui viennent
d'arriver qui sont très sympas mais il
ya d'autres choses qui viennent
d'arriver notamment pour mettre dans vos
oreilles ce sont les bucks 2 samsung
galaxy buzz deux fois extrêmement précis
au niveau du nom alors ces buzz de ils
sont intéressants 149 euros 149 euros
donc ça peut tout à fait venir coller
avec l'offre l'offre de lancement qu'on
a en ce moment chez samsung sur sur le
galaxy z flip 3 sur l'égal accès de
folie 3 il avait remis et donc ses
galaxy 2 2 ils sont géniaux puisqu'on
est venue alors c'est la porte d'entrée
en fin de compte dans les écouteurs sans
fil donc les écouteurs trouvés relate
chez samsung
et donc on est sur un prix d'appel à 149
euros et pour la première fois sur un
prix d'appel aussi bas chez samsung on
embarque une technologie de réduction du
bruit active donc ça c'est très sympa on
a fait on a travaillé énormément la
partie déjà la partie design puisque ce
sont des écouteurs qui ne pèse que 5
grammes chacun avec qui ce fonds qui se
font facilement oubliées dans vos
oreilles qui fit parfaitement dans le
conduit auditif donc on en est très
content et à côté de sa voix la cdc des
petites pépites qui sont disponibles en
plusieurs couleurs donc là on a la tête
à la couleur lavande zappé voyage vous
prouvera en provence en jeu donc là on a
le vert olive oui fait voyager encore
ailleurs et pour l'apéro ça se fera mais
aussi d'ailleurs c'est l'heure pour y
aller et la mer dons et les les couleurs
noir les couleurs blanche donc on a il y
en a pour tous les goûts ils viennent
parfaitement finalement se coordonner
avec les différents coloris qu'on peut
trouver sur les autres chaussures les ou
sur les smartphones tu sais le truc est
sympa avec sa compagne et moi c'est
qu'en fait si vous regardez regardez je
parlais en faire un petit jeu en fait
sont toutes blanches oui donc vous savez
parce qu'à l'intérieur vous pouvez juste
le voir par le liseret exactement
lancions blanc c'est blanc sur blanc
prendra là on voit le petit un tollé
donc c'est très discret et on peut
deviner si on experts quels coloris on a
essayé il ya un côté un peu illégaux et
ça j'aime bien exact du rigolo mois
exactement balata le petit liseré
lavande jeudi noir dont tu devines
projet les évidemment la voilà la
couleur quotas donc donc c'est des haut
parleurs à kg qui sont qui sont
directement dans ses écouteurs donc on
délivre une une qualité une qualité
audio bang qui est digne de chez samsung
qui est qui ont rendez vous avec cette
réduction de bruit actif qui vous
permettra vraiment de vous immerger dans
votre dans votre monde une fois que une
fois que vous avez les écouteurs dans
les oreilles comment elle fonctionne
cette réduction de bruit vous avez
d'être plusieurs micros du coup il ya
plusieurs micros il ya trois micros qui
sont qui vient d'être embarqué en fait
enfin de conclure sur chaque écouteur
qui vont permettre de venir capter les
bruits extérieurs pour bat pour tout
simplement annuler le bruit au maximum
en plus de la réduction de bruit que tu
as de manière native puisque le format
de l'extérieur c'est d'intra
auriculaires donc c'est une réduction de
bruit passif qu'il avoue boucher les
oreilles ça exactement dans un premier
temps et à côté de ça on va venir
envoyer un signal inverse de l'undd
sonore qui que les micros on détectait
qu'on fait du buzz voilà m équipé d'un
double et du coup en plus de cette
réduction passive on va avoir la
réduction de bruit active qui va venir
vraiment vous immerger au maximum dans
votre musique dans les films dans les
séries que vous êtes en train de en
train de regarder comme c'est très très
sympa à un prix de 49 à un prix de 149
euros exactement 6 49 euros ck2 les îles
149 euros c'est déjà très très bien
pouvez y aller alors bon voilà pour ces
nouveautés voulu qu'on en parle
maintenant je comprends vraiment dans le
fond du sujet ce qui nous intéresse
c'est ce qu'on va retrouver du côté du
smartphone alors moi j'en ai déjà parlé
sur ma chaîne et c'est très très cool
mais comme on également sur le site de
la fnac en direct à des personnes qui ne
connaissent pas qui ne savent pas qu'ils
ont besoin d'information et vous avez
raison rester connecté parce qu'on est
encore là pendant un petit moment on a
deux smartphones on va avoir samsung
galaxy z fold 3 c'est là où on a un
grand format et qu'on vient ensuite
replié pour arriver sur un plus petit
format tout à fait et le contraire c'est
ce qu'on a avec le z flip trois jours
dans l'es3 il y en a que deux mais c'est
2,3 pour autant dans le même nom en fait
pour suivre la course devient va avoir
une cohérence de gamme tout à fait alors
en fin de compte on a eu deux flips de
galaxy z flip qui sont sortis a eu un
galaxy z flip de première génération et
galaxy tab flip 5g braqués avait été
légèrement remanié par rapport à la
première génération est donc là on
arrive à la troisième génération d'où le
galaxy z trip 3 bravo et en plus de la
cohérence de gamme aussi pour fitter
parfaitement avec avec le galaxy z folle
de 3 que dont on va se parler je viserai
fait ce qui est super intéressant avec
ça c'est qu'on voit qu'est ce qu'on
arrive à faire avec un écran qui
explique on voit qu'un écran qui se plie
va servir effectivement hop là je suis
la caméra je suis trop vite ça ça ça a
effectivement réduire l'encombrement
donc assez génial et l'autre sert à
ouvrir davantage alors on est vraiment
dans deux univers différents tout à fait
on se concentre d'abord sur le z cheval
de troie on commence par z part égal
accès de folie croire ça n'allait pas sa
magnifique alors le zèle folle de trois
on est sur du pliable laurie soit leur
productivité dorothée on est sur la
productivité davantage on est sûr de là
je dirais sur une immersion qui est la
plus sympa possible avec un grand écran
comme celui ci est donc une fois que
effectivement tu as tu as ce produit là
qui qui peut s'utiliser comme un
smartphone classique quand quand tu le
laisses fermée une fois que tu louvre tu
as ce grand écran hop il détecte les
bugs se connecter tu as eu grand écran
de 7,6 pousse donc qui est absolument
génial et en fin de compte on est venu
vraiment travailler cette partie écran
pour finalement proposer une immersion
la plus totale dans le contenu des
utilisateurs si on peut le voir
directement sur la sur la came radio
donc c'est super juste là donc je sais
pas s'il va à présent pour vous ouvrir
une vidéo sur une vidéo ans et moi c'est
toi tu as préparé ton coup j'ai vu et du
coup qu'on peut effectivement lancé une
vidéo donc là l'idée c'est qu'on est
venu en fin de compte on est venu
travailler la partie caméra frontale
puisque la caméra frontale vient
directement se loger sous l'écran est en
fait l'idée c'est que cette caméra
frontale à se fasse oublier donc quand
vous regarder l'écran qui est juste là
vous avez la caméra qui se trouve juste
là étaient planqués qui est planqué
l'idée c'est qu'il se fasse oublier
quand vous regardez des films quand vous
regarder des séries quand vous regardez
des vidéos et
pour que vous n'ayez finalement plus
aucun élément perturbateur si si je puis
dire comme on pouvait avoir jusqu'à
présent avec un poinçon qui laissait
apparaître la caméra la caméra frontale
et donc là cette caméra frontale va
servir est essentiellement en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on recommande chez samsung à
faire des visions et donc du coup ça
permet d'avoir une immersion vraiment
total dans l'ensemble des contenus donc
ça c'est très très sympa ça c'est la
grosse innovation qu'on attendait de
samsung qui vient d'arriver qui est
super intéressant sur ce produit
exactement au delà de ça alors pas tant
pour le le contenu visionnage de films
et séries mais je pense au gaming on a
deux écrans deux écrans la vue
intérieure et extérieure on a deux
écrans avec un taux de rafraîchissement
de 120 hertz à chaque fois une le
bénéfice c'est quoi alors c'est un taux
de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz
adaptatif je pense que c'est
effectivement intéressant intéressant de
le souligner adaptatif parce qu'il va
venir donc c'est un taux de
rafraîchissement une fluidité qui va
venir s'adapter en fonction des besoins
que vous avez sur votre smartphone donc
effectivement quand vous allez scrollé
quand vous allez jouer à des jeux vous
aurez une fluidité qui sera maximale
pour avoir un confort visuel qui est le
meilleur possible en revanche si jamais
vous n'avez pas besoin d'un taux de
rafraîchissement est d'une fluidité qui
soit aussi poussé évidemment le
smartphone l'intelligence artificielle
du smartphone détecte oracle n'avait pas
besoin reviendra sur un taux de
rafraîchissement une fluidité un petit
peu moindre ça permet de sauvegarder de
la batterie donc avoir du 120 hertz
adaptative des deux côtés puisque
auparavant ne l'avait pas sur l'écran
fermé sur l'écran de couverture c'est le
cas maintenant donc l'idée c'était de
pousser une expérience visuelle qui soit
la même aussi fluide que possible tant
sur la partie
écran voilà intérieur que sur la partie
extérieure ça c'est top non c'est super
c'était une demande des utilisateurs
aussi d'avoir finalement une expérience
qui soit sensiblement la même entre les
deux écrans jusqu'à présent on avait un
taux de 60 hertz taux de
rafraîchissement de 60 hertz sur la face
avant donc sur le galaxy cette folle de
2 l'année dernière donc là on est venu
retravailler cette partie écran
extérieur pour le rendre plus fluide
plus agréable en lecture de contenus
d'accord donc un produit qui a évolué
aussi au niveau de la fabrication on le
voit sur le contenu multimédia on va
venir à voir avec cette caméra sous
l'écran plus de diversion plus de
fluidité lorsqu'on va venir jouer à des
jeux mais aussi une conception qui
évolue alors cette fois un peu plus
compliqué du point de vue consommateur
parce que des choses dont on ne se rend
pas compte c'est à dire que moi je
prends un smartphone je regarde un z
folle de deux jardins est folle de 3
jeudi son bien mais pour autant il ya
moins changement en profondeur qui a été
effectué au niveau du êtes folle de 3
ouais tout à fait en fin de compte on
est venu finalement répondre à une
requête
d'une part de nos utilisateurs et de
beaucoup de personnes qui hésitent
encore à passer départ du smartphone
pliable pour des contraintes de enfin
pour des raisons de voilà je sais
personne doute probablement de la
solidité des produits et de la
robustesse général et en fin de compte
on est venu apporter des garanties à ce
niveau là la première garantie c'est
déjà un aluminium un d aluminium les
plus résistants de l'industrie qui vient
entourer le smartphone donc ça c'est
très cool on est venu sur la face
arrière de l'aide du smartphone à poser
du gorille la glace victime donc c'est
un des verts les plus résistantes
l'industrie qui le rend beaucoup plus
résistant aux chocs et des ristournes
tournoi exactement tout à fait et la
vraie évolution qu'on est venu apporter
c'est sur cet écran interne donc déjà
dans un premier temps cet écran interne
il a été testé pour être ouvert et fermé
en tout cas certifié pour être ouvert et
fermé deux cent mille fois j'ai essayé
je me suis arrêté à sa compo voilà donc
deux cent mille fois ça représente
environ 100 ouvertures et fermetures par
jour pendant cinq ans c'est donc voilà
ça veut pas dire qu'elle à 200000 1e
fois à l'écran le cas sera évidemment
c'est qu'il est certifié qu'il est
certifié au moins 200 millions
exactement
cet écran interne il a été également
renforcée puisqu'il est 80% plus
résistant que la génération précédente
en fin de compte on est venu à poser une
nouvelle surcouche à l'issue de cet
écran qui vient supplier donc ce verre
ultra ultra fin on est venu à poser une
nouvelle couche qui rend le smartphone
plus raisonnable au plus résistants
pardon aux chocs et aux rayures tout 80
% par rapport à la génération précédente
donc ça c'est très très cool et
finalement la l'innovation de taille sur
ce produit là tu veux que je voulais en
venir je pense c'est bien sûr la
résistance à l'eau ouais c'est ça c'est
quand même assez faut en fait parce que
tu te dis que tu as un smartphone qui se
plie donc a forcément un moment où tu
peux avoir de l'eau quelque chose qui
rentrent tout à fait assez résiste ces
résistants à l'eau alors les ingénieurs
de chez samsung ils ont travaillé très
dur dans la conception de ce téléphone
pour bat pour venir finalement certifier
une résistance à l'eau c'était aussi une
finalement une demande des utilisateurs
de galaxies date paul ii et galaxy z
philippe 5 g l'an dernier c'était de de
pouvoir utiliser un smartphone sous la
pluie sans crainte donc il y avait
certains certaines personnes qui
craignaient d'utiliser smartphones sous
la pluie ou en cas de chute accidentelle
dans de l'eau douce ne pas avoir peur de
ba2 que le smartphone ne fonctionne plus
donc on est venu apporter cette
certification ipx8 qu'il rend résistant
à l'eau jusqu'à un mètre cinquante de
profondeur pendant 30 minutes et donc ça
c'est une vraie garantie supplémentaire
de solidité et de robustesse pour le
téléphone donc on peut mais on peut le
faire tomber dans l'eau de manière
accidentelle dans de l'eau douce pas de
soucis vous pouvez récupérer le
téléphone il continuera de fonctionner
de la même façon s'il pleut et que vous
êtes en train d'utiliser votre
smartphone sous la pluie comme ça a été
beaucoup le cas cette année
en tout cas à paris c'est un gage de
sécurité ce bloc est donc là
effectivement on voit qu'il ya un très
gros travail qui a été fait du point de
vue matériel mais aussi une super
expérience logiciels alors qu'on
retrouve bien évidemment sur l'ensemble
des produits smartphones samsung
s'appelle ou a dû animer la one way
était encore plus loin pour s'adapter un
format qui est vraiment particulier en
fait le staff un smartphone qui explique
tu peux nous raconter un peu haut niveau
est ce qu'on peut faire avec ouais alors
le one way c'est beaucoup de choses en
fin de compte chez samsung on est venu
travailler un certain nombre de
deux choses sur la partie logicielle
déjà on est venu retravailler la partie
applicative mais côté samsung par
exemple un samsung note que tu vois ici
a
été retravaillé pour être bas pour être
optimisé sur un écran de 7,6 pouces
comme celui ci donc ça c'est très sympa
la même façon si vous allez dans les
paramètres d'un samsung galaxy s2 folle
de 3 on a ces deux volets qui sont
totalement indépendants et que vous
pouvez utiliser de manière indépendante
donc ça c'est un gain de temps en terme
pour en termes de productivité et un
gain de temps général quand vous voulez
trouver vite le paramètre que vous
souhaitez etc etc donc ça c'est c'est un
travail colossal qui a été fait côté
logiciel chez samsung on est mieux
travailler aussi avec de nombreux
acteurs tels que google facebook ou
microsoft pour revenir optimiser
l'exploitation d'applications et
l'utilisation d'applications sur un
écran comme celui ci c'était un retour
des utilisateurs sur le galaxy sur le
galaxy et de folle de l'an dernier
instagram
c'était le tient je pense aussi
instagram désormais est utilisable sur
un grand écran comme comme celui du
galaxy cette folle de 3 l'année dernière
vous aviez des petites des bandes sur
les côtés d'écouté way est donc là on
est venu travailler conjointement avec
les ingénieurs logiciels de chez
facebook pour venir optimisé
là les applications de facebook
instagram etc etc c'est le cas pour
spotify aussi donc spotify à une
organisation totalement différente sur
sur la face avant donc là c'est par
exemple on écoute un titre de georgia
smith l'avoir en font comme ça mais si
vous basculez sur l'ensemble des menus
vous avez toujours cette colonne
latérale qui est qui est très agréable
et puis après vous pouvez naviguer
directement dans l'artiste et puis vous
avez des autres menus qui sont qui sont
très très cool aussi wathelet d'ouvrir
aux distributions en fait de l'espace tu
va utiliser différents exactement l'idée
c'était de d'apporter plus de
productivité d'apporter plus de
qui dirait une meilleure expérience
globale et plus d'intuitivité
pourparlers pour les gens et pour les
utilisateurs de ce format de smartphones
qui est changeant évidemment donc est
donc ici ça fait sens je pense à google
aussi dont google a été vraiment
optimisé pour être utilisée sur sur un
smartphone comme celui ci donc
typiquement si tu es en format portrait
times l'interface google assez classique
avec un volet latéral qui vient se caler
sur la gauche en revanche si tu bascules
en format paysage on a informé un petit
peu plus comme sur pc qui va venir faire
sens dans des soucis de productivité
additionnel avec un volet ici
indépendant de ce que tu peux trouver
ici si tu veux lire tes mails comme ça
où comme ça ça c'est très très sympa
donc tu vois on est venu on est lui
vraiment bossé avec
je dirais beaucoup de sociétés
émettrices d'applications pour voilà
pour optimiser l'exploitation de toutes
ces applications sur sur un format aussi
particulier que celui ci on rentre un
petit peu dans la productivité on se dit
ok allez moi par exemple je suis en
train de travailler il le faut j'en sais
rien tableur excel du world peut
importer pour autant j'ai envie à côté
et bien d'avoir du tout je ne sais pas
quoi sur youtube alors tu peux faire du
multitâche là dessus ouais tiens alors
tu peux faire du multitâche bien sûr que
tu te montrer comment ça va fonctionner
convient certes il crée alors je sais
pas on peut par exemple ouvrir une vidéo
sur youtube la tienne par exemple et on
se dit qu'on prend des notes pendant qu
on est en train de regarder la vidéo
pendant qu'on est en train de faire une
vision donc évidemment le multitâche
prend tout son sens sur un écran aussi
grand que celui ci donc si j'ai envie
par exemple d'ouvrir
une vidéo sur youtube et de l'avoir en
affichage ce qu'on appelle un affichage
fractionné je peux la voir un petit peu
comme ça et je vais ouvrir mes notes
de samsung notes et enfin toute la force
de ce produit c'est qu'il dispose d'une
charnière d'une charnière à position
libre et qu'on va venir positionner
toute nature voilà tu te mets exactement
où tu veux et alors d'être bien milieu
voilà je mets bien au milieu donc là le
smartphone est plié et donc là on peut
lancer la vidéo juste là et puis
commencer à prendre des notes soit en
dactylographiées soit avec le s pen oui
transition après tout trouvé pour
pour pour le pour prendre des notes donc
alors ces valeurs pour une vidéo mais
c'est valable aussi pour je dirais pour
pour une vision que vous êtes en train
de faire donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
était qui était vraiment demandé voilà
on a un format qui elle qui est mieux
donc c'est très utile et ça et ça fait
sens dans des soucis de production
malgré juste le plan ou yes guimbal
descendre que juste à la merci beaucoup
et on le voit vachement bien ou tel
talent est lié au dessus la vidéo qui
basculent sur qui bascule enfin qui est
qui est en train de tourner sur l'écran
du dessus ouais est ton état prise de
notes qui peut qui peut qui peut se
faire en qui peut se faire sur la partie
basse de l'écran alors merci d'avoir
fait la transition sur le besoin de la
place et ça c'est intéressant parce
qu'en fait c'est une vraie nouveauté
sont tous des nouveautés mais on va
beaucoup plus loin en termes d'usagés
parce que on voit ce smartphone et
malgré toutes les belles évolutions qui
l'a clos d'un point de vue logiciel et
matériel on est sur un form factor pour
koné qu'on a déjà vu les années
précédentes même si il en train de se
démocratiser davantage mais l'arrivée du
splc nouveau et ça lui attendent
vraiment de nouveaux horizons et un
nouvel usage enfin c'est vraiment
intéressant qu'est ce que je viens faire
en attaque soleil qu'est ce que ça va
payer vraiment ma portée bah alors tout
ce que finalement tu pouvais faire avec
un s pen sur sur les sur les autres
produits de l'écosystème galaxy sur une
tablette sur un ace 21,8 rade sur un
galaxy note donc tu vas venir faire tout
ce que voilà tout ce que les
utilisateurs adorent faire avec le
respect donc ça va être de la prise de
notes ça va être du dessin ça va être de
la retouche photo sur lightroom par
exemple est une chose que les
effectivement que les gens et que les
utilisateurs adorent faire avec le
respect c'est de la traduction de textes
en temps réel donc si vous êtes sûr sur
google par exemple
donc là vous avez un texte en anglais
qui s'affiche et donc en fait avec le s
pen tu peux directement allé dans un
onglet traduction
pour traduire par exemple sont un
paragraphe soit 1 soit un seul mot donc
l'âge et choisir un paragraphe et on va
sélectionner ce paragraphe pour avoir
une traduction en temps réel et puis
après on a juste tel quel on dirait
tattoo exactement c'est très pratiques
et donc ça c'est très cool hop j'ai pas
sélectionné l'ensemble mais métal idée
donc je peux faire finalement tout ce
que les gens adorent et faire avec leur
avec le respect auparavant sur leurs
galaxies no to suffer galaxy tab ou sur
leur galaxy s 21 ultra hockey la prise
de notes du dessin de la retouche photo
la traduction en temps réel comme ceci
donc pour autant vous avez deux aspects
qui sont sortis cette année ça c'est
intéressant et c'est vraiment très on va
dire surprenant de voir deux semaines
qui arrivent alors ça c'est le fold
edition tout à fait c'est jeter couple
exclu non mais c'est moi qui t'ai
pouvais je suis désolé le saas et le spm
foladi jal et on a développé un autre
espagne qui est le s pen pro donc cela
semaine folle d'edition il est au prix
de 49 euros le s pen près au prix de 99
euros et en fin de compte le s pen folle
d'edition il est venu être finalement
conçu spécifiquement et exclusivement
pour être utilisée sur le galaxy de paul
iii doit être adaptée en fin de compte à
cet écran pliable donc ça veut dire que
si celui là je le prends et je veux
utiliser sur mon samsung galaxy ace
ventura il ne fonctionnera pas non
d'accord c'est à dire quoi ça fait de la
mine en fait ouais ça vient de la mine
en fin de compte qui a été spécialement
conçue pour être utilisée sur un
smartphone pliable hockey puisque vu que
la conception d'un smartphone pliable le
verre est différent on est venu
forcément apporter une attention
particulière à la conception de ce
stylet et ce style est si vous êtes si
vous appuyez un petit peu trop fort va
venir se rétracter ok dans un souci de
ne pas évidemment abîmé l'écran et le s
pen pro quant à lui à des mines
interchangeables c'est pour ça que le s
pen pro est compatible avec l'ensemble
des appareils de l'écosystème galaxy et
tu vas pouvoir en fin de compte
interchanger les mines en fonction du
device que tu serais en train d'utiliser
dans lequel tu utiliseras lgv est donc
ça veut dire que si par exemple tu as
uniquement photonics est déjà très bien
samsung galaxy z fold 3 tu prends le
faux l'edition mais si par contre dans
l'écosystème samsung et que tu vas voir
une tablette à côté notamment ce qui me
paraîtra un peu plus logique d'avoir une
tablette que d'avoir un réseau ultra et
galaxy forfait ce que vous voulez chez
vous allez voir c'est pas sa maison qui
vous dira le contraire mais du coup
effectivement à ce moment là on va
plutôt s'orienter sur le modèle
professionnel tout à fait ok t'as fait
sur le s pen croquis qui va venir être
compatible avec l'ensemble des appareils
de l'écosystème galaxies que vous pouvez
avoir chez vous la smart phones qui est
performant également vous avez le plus
gros processeur de qualcomm si on peut
rigoler 888 tout à fait donc les affaire
avec 12 giga de ram
il est disponible en deux versions donc
en 256 gigauri 512 go de stockage
évidemment il est wi-fi 6 il est
compatible 5 g donc on est venu vraiment
boosté la partie spec la partie
performance pour avoir en fin de compte
juste un smartphone qui puisse répondre
au doigt et à l'oeil à l'ensemble de vos
envies on parlait tout à l'heure de
d'immersion et si on jouait à la
performance on a aussi deux haut
parleurs stéréo de qualité hall de l'uby
atmos évidemment ça fait sens quand vous
êtes en train de regarder vos films et
vos séries préférées sur sur votre sueur
pour deux galaxies de foule de 3 pour
être immergé encore plus sûres sur
l'ensemble des contrôles donc là c'est
un smartphone qui à 1799 euros sur la
version 256 go de stockage tout à fait
1899 euros en version 512 go de stockage
n'oubliez pas vous avez le code samsung
en entier samsung st100 qui vous permet
d'avoir 100 euros de remise ça c'est
vachement bien et en plus des 150 euros
qui sont voilà et en plus 150 euros qui
vous sont offertes sur une sélection
d'accessoires donc ça peut être une
coque ça peut être un espion je le
disais tout à l'heure mais ça peut être
aussi des galaxy 2 2 qui sont au prix de
549 euros donc ça vous offre les les les
écouteurs dernier dernier né des
écouteurs de samsung les galaxy 2 alors
là on parle effectivement du smartphone
qui est vraiment axée sur la
productivité mais il ya un autre
smartphone qui est sympa aussi très
sympa mais qui est un peu différent qui
est plus dans le lifestyle zézette flip
3 toutes les applis pts 3 pour voir
qu'on est sur du pliable et raconte une
histoire qui est vraiment différente
c'est je prends mon smartphone déjà je
me la pète parce qu'ils sont plus
épanouis blazy martin qui explique et en
plus de se la péter eh bien on a un vrai
gain de place on a de nouveaux usages
notamment sur le côté photo un peu
poudrier mais ça on va développer dans
les instants donc c'est un smartphone
qui revient avec un écran qui a vraiment
évolué par rapport à ce qu'on avait sur
la première génération ça nous a déjà
des infos toulouse où il y avait de la
5g qu'est ce qu'il raconte sur alors
celui-là est très différent il est très
différent et pour autant il a beaucoup
de similitudes avec avec son grand frère
le galaxy cette folle 3 donc le gerets
et de philippe iii déjà il est 16 format
qui est génial tu le disais tout à
l'heure alors est ce que je me la pète
quand j'ai un galaxy 2 flippant mais là
je sais pas rires je me la pète je sais
pas je suis moi je suis comme ça je vais
payer en fin de compte on est venu
répondre à une demande de compacité des
utilisateurs en fin de compte on est
dans une dans une industrie où les
écrans sont de plus en plus grands et du
coup en ce sens
d'après d'après les études qu'on a mené
chez samsung on s'est rendu compte qu'à
vrai qu'il y avait un vrai désir de
revenir à des smartphones vraiment
compact qu'ils puissent facilement tenir
dans une poche ou dans un sac
sans pour autant faire de compromis sur
la partie écran et donc c'est pour cette
raison qu'on est venu travailler ce côté
design et donc on reprend les codes du
design du galaxy de philippe de l'an
dernier donc quand tu louvre tu as ce
grand écran de 6,7 pouces qui full hd +
qui est en 120 hertz adaptative donc ça
c'est une nouveauté également par
rapport à l'année dernière on est venu
apporter une fluidité qui est qui est
super trop beau et une fois que vous le
plier et donc la tête et bah voilà vous
avez fait un axe et à différents toi
c'est fou parce que le tien les maths le
mien il est brillant oui alors en fait
il est disponible en quatre couleurs ce
galaxy z trip 3 vallées dont les à la
voix on peut vous peut les montrer et
c'est ça c'est ça c'est le vert donc il
ya 4 4 coloris qui sont disponibles il
ya le vert le noir qui lui est mat leur
crème et un coloris l'avant qui lui est
brillant donc il ya le vers la vendée le
crem qui sont des coloris brillant et
une teinte mate avec le avec le noir
fait dire que si je me dois me présenter
sa solution match et le tout à fait tout
à fait tu peux venir match et tu as
galaxie watch quatre avec la couleur
verte avec le avec ce smartphone là donc
ça c'est très très sympa aussi donc il
des synergies comme ça n'enlève pas ce
qu'on peut pas de
badge et à décoder l'a déjà vu donc on
est venu vraiment travailler cette
partie design et notamment l'écran
externe que tu peux voir ici donc c'est
écran externe une fois que l'idée en fin
de compte de ce produit c'était de
pouvoir l'utiliser sans même avoir à
l'ouvrir
c'était une requête et c'était
d'ailleurs le dirait la requête numéro
une des utilisateurs l'an dernier
c'était de faire un smartphone afin de
faire un écran sur la partie fermée du
smartphone qui soit plus grands et
qu'ils soient plus utilisés c'est vrai
que sur la v1 qui était très bien et
très novatrice on avait un tout petit
écran notification et mises à part
quelques petits messages et un petit
bout en se concentrant photo on est un
petit peu limité oui quand tu nous la
présente est ce que tu nous la présenter
merci à toi bravo et félicitations aux
initiés du coup ça ouvre des
perspectives et sur la partie photo
c'est quand même vachement cool sur la
partie notification sur la partie
musique écouter un morceau semaine
notify on peut vraiment contrôler des
choses absolument accessoires sais pas
non non c'est pas un jeu alors comme
chez les et l'idée c'était de pouvoir
utiliser le smartphone sans même avoir à
l'ouvrir donc si par exemple je
tu vois que j'aime beaucoup jean jasmin
mais si je balance si je lance une
musique effectivement geste écran
externe qui nous qui me permet de qui me
permet de la de contrôler la musique
puisqu'on à spotify qui tourne way qui
tourne ici donc là on peut mettre sur un
peu mettre en pause la musique elle peut
passer au morceau suivant on peut passer
au morceau précédent donc c'était quand
externe il nous permet de faire plein
d'autres choses en plus de contrôler sa
musique évidemment ils indiquent l'heure
mais il permet clic encore à pratiquer
quand même mais de consulter la météo
de déclencher samsung ace de dérogation
de santé en lien avec tom on exactement
c'est là où on est dans l'écosystème
exactement tout à fait déclencher un
minuteur il ya votre chauffe été tes
yeux par exemple et je suis déclenché un
minuteur sans même avoir ouvrir ton
smartphone samsung paye également on en
parle moins mais voilà de pouvoir payer
avec samsung paye chez son commerçant
donc tu vas acheter ta baguette et vu
que tu as ton capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui vient se loger directement
sur le côté du smartphone tu poses ton
doigt tu payes avec samsung keita même
pas eu besoin d'ouvrir afin d'ouvrir le
smartphone pour pouvoir utile pour
pouvoir l'utiliser donc ça c'est très
très cool et tu le montrait tout à
l'heure c'est la partie photo j'adore
c'est à dire que j'aime beaucoup c'est à
dire que la partie photo tu peut
l'activer
juste là comme ça et donc tu peux
attendre attendre refait le en en live
way you lie alors regarde hop je double
appui sur le sur le sur le bouton
d'alimentation est donc là je peut
basculer en grand-angle en ultra
grand-angle et donc je peux prendre mais
celle fille en faisant ça j'étais comme
juste avec la main et au delà le cmfi
élan donc ça c'est très sympa pour avoir
un retour sur sur les sur les photos
peut-être un terme qui est génial en
plus de ça c'est que quand toi tu veux
prendre quelqu'un en photo est comme ça
tu es dans ton applications jeux de
prendre en photo comme ça je reviendrais
à tout le monde et je vais c'est vrai
j'étais là je te jure et dont tu peut
activer l'écran extérieurs tout à fait
là j'étais pas activé je peux plus
révoltant
voilà j'ai activé donc là tu te vois toi
donc tu vois que tu te prends vraiment
aux photos et la shdm appuyé fait moins
sourire tag voilà
je suis vraiment donc non ça c'est
vachement pratique tout à fait tu peux
avoir un retour de la personne que tu
prends en photo enfin la personne peut
avoir un retour de la photo qui est en
train d'être prises et pour autant on
est sur un écran super amoled on est sur
mon écran super amoled à l'extérieur et
voilà qui est qui et qui est tactile et
qui vient de quatre fois plus grand que
la génération précédente c'est là où il
y avait un gros progrès j'ai pas parlé
de ça tout à l'heure mais on peut
évidemment lire ces notifications quand
on reçoit des whatsapp quand on reçoit
des messages désormais vous pouvez
scrollé pour lire l'intégralité de la
notification directement sur cet écran
externe donc encore une fois la
philosophie de ce smartphone une fois
fermée s'équipent ils puissent être
utilisable à souhait de manière beaucoup
plus poussée que sur un génération de
l'an dernier pour pour être utilisée
sans l'ouvrir bon je me permets de faire
une petite piqûre de rappel sur les
codes promo utilisable sur fnac.com et
uniquement sur fnac.com samsung sans ça
me saoule en entier vous collez 100
derrière un 0-0 et ça me permet d'avoir
100 euros de remise jusqu'au 15
septembre
et ça c'est chouette donc allez faire un
plus tôt son site de la fnac parce que
si vous voulez effectivement acheté un
de ses preuves sur le z folle de 3 ou le
z fils 300 euros de reduc c'est quand
même pas rien surtout moi qui suis au
vert risque d'assumer ça me fait plaisir
tout ce qui est pris ta plante voilà
donc ça c'est vachement bien être aussi
un smartphone qui a aussi une
fabrication peu plus robustes par
rapport à ce qu'on avait avant une vraie
évolution également ouais je te parlais
de points communs avec le galaxy de
folle de trois doigts chaleur c'est là
on se rejoint on est venu apporter les
mêmes garanties sur ce galaxy de flip 3
que sur le galaxy z folle de 3 pour
répondre finalement à aux personnes qui
hésitent à passer le pas de publier
parce qu'ils jugent le forme un petit
peu trop fragiles ou pas assez robuste
donc on est venu apporter les mêmes
garanties on est une certification des
temps de résistance à l'eau ouais donc
vous pouvez l'utiliser sous la pluie
vous pouvez le faire tomber dans de
l'eau douce jusqu'à un mètre cinquante
de profondeur pendant 30 minutes le
smartphone sera résistant on est venu
mettre un aluminium un d aluminium les
plus résistants sur le côté c'est du
verre gorilla glass
victime comme chante également
exactement comme je regrette cette folle
3 qui vient protéger toute cette partie
arrière de l'écran et on est venu de la
même façon renforcer l' écran interne
qui est 80% plus résistant que la
génération précédente et donc ça c'est
top et puis alors finalement c'est assez
bête mais l'argument le plus simple
qu'on pourrait proposer là dessus c'est
que une fois que tu fermes ta smartphone
bâton écran il est toujours protégé donc
là t'as plus forcément tu as pu être
souciés de si jamais je fais tomber mon
smartphone par inadvertance de casser
l'écran une fois que le smartphone est
protégé une fois que le smartphone est
fermé par dont l'écran est toujours
protégé total ça c'est quand même ça ça
c'est vachement bien et alors du coup au
smartphone avec un écran intérieur avec
un taux de rafraîchissement autre 104
262 120 hertz le mec qui bug c'est la
fin de journée 100 verges oui exactement
triki 10180 de son nom 120 g koné
passait très bien donc pour le contenu
multimédia c'est la journée alors le
bénéfice pour moi pas forcément comme ça
c'est aussi quand on vient ce crowley
tout un scénario sur mais sur instagram
jusque rôle je crois parce que je me
fous du troll est bien fait ça fait
fouillis donc c'est mieux pour l'oeil
c'est plus reposant et c'est beaucoup
plus qualitatif
aux smartphones extrêmement puissant
également je vais avoir le snapdragon
888 à l'intérieur qualcomm ouais on est
venus doper vraiment cette fiche produit
là encore pour bat pour venir répondre
aux attentes des utilisateurs de ce
format là de galaxy z ce clip on a voulu
vraiment proposer un smartphone qui est
ultra puissant et qui puisse le suivre
partout en fait tant sur la partie
robustesse avec ça c'était ça c'était
très important que sur la partie
performance et ça c'est ça ça nous
tenait à coeur donc justin dragonne 5
888 8 gigas de ram évidemment le
téléphone et 5 g il est wi-fi 6
également donc on embarque on embarque
des performances qui sont dignes de ce
nom et qui sont vraiment intéressantes
sur un smartphone comme celui ci haut
parleurs stéréo également exactement
haut parleurs j'allais le dire j'avais
vu plus en dépenses et givors je suis un
truc quand même haut-parleurs stéréo
ouais pareil quand tu es en train de
regarder ta vidéo tu tu as tes haut
parleurs stéréo de qualité dolby a tenu
bon et ça c'est toujours appréciable
pour regarder ces séries et ses vidéos
sur youtube ou ailleurs exactement alors
y ait quelqu'un dont je parlais tout à
l'heure justement notre production self
et quand tu veux prendre ton ton
smartphone études mais sur la partie
photo eh bien il ya ce qu'on va venir
appelé le flex menacé par une petite
caméra quelque part s'il vous plaît
petite caméra après une petite caméra
ses mots donc là on voit en fait qu'on a
toute la partie là et quoi je vais
oublier eh bien ça vient légèrement
c'est à dire s'adapter ça fait partie
effectivement l'expérience soit une
nouvelle qui est complètement adapté ici
écrit seulement pas tu peux parler un
peu de ce flex no way alors il ya plein
de énormément d'applications qui ont été
optimisés pour être utilisé en flex mode
et en fin de compte ce flex mode il y a
bien changé totalement les usages sur
sur un smartphone comme celui ci puisque
avec le galaxy de flip 3 t'as plus
besoin quand tu fais tes vidéos par
exemple de tenir ton smartphone comme ça
pour être bas pour être en visio avec je
sais pas qui fin en ce qui me concerne
j'étais en visio avec ma famille pendant
le premier confinement non-stop
donc là le fait d'avoir et donc du coup
tout le temps avec mon smartphone comme
ça et donc le fait d'avoir un smartphone
qui simplement vient si on active
l'appareil photo vient se poser comme ça
sur la table et qui vous permet de faire
vos visio sans même avoir à le tenir
c'est quand même très confortable c'est
quand même très agréable et de la même
façon tu peux imaginer de prendre celle
fille tu peux imaginer de te prendre ans
elle fit en posant téléphone ici et puis
et puis voilà est il exact la moto et ça
c'est ça c'est quand même très sympa
ouais c'est hip hop là donc donc le flex
mode il vient jouer un rôle là dedans
même quand tu regarde des vidéos sur
youtube je sais pas si je peux avoir la
caméra qui vient sommes juste là et
qu'on sélectionne par exemple monsieur
gros une vidéo une vidéo de toi quand
même pas bons c'est louche qui nous le
suivrons est donc en fin de compte on va
avoir la vidéo qui va venir
automatiquement s'ajuster à si je trouve
hop le test du à 52,5 vue est magnifique
qui va venir s'adapter en fonction de la
vidéo que tu es en train de consulter
avec la partie
up la partie haute qui va venir
directement en grand écran optimisé et
avec une indépendance totale de la
partie basse de l'écran et donc ça c'est
très sympa donc voila quand tu quand tu
louvre t'es tu es un écran qui est
totale et dès que tu le pli tu as la
vidéo qui va venir s'ajuster donc ça
c'est valable pour énormément
d'applications qui vont venir ce petit
musée de cette manière là pour être
utilisé que la meilleure manière sûre
sur ce galaxy explique 3 c'est génial
c'est un smartphone rappelle-moi le prix
ce smartphone il il a été lancé à 1059
euros en version 128 giga et à 1109
euros en version 256 go 10 500 euros à
49 euros je le note passe
etc ces 500 euros de moins que la
génération précédente qui avait été l'an
dernier que le galaxy z flip singles ça
c'est vraiment des points forts qui n'a
vraiment surpris le jour on en a parlé
sur les présentations presse avant que
le produit soit lancée c'est
effectivement la politique tarifaire
elle est complètement incroyable c'est à
dire qu'en fait ça vient vraiment
démocratiser le smartphone pliable et là
en plus ce qui est dingue et je sais pas
pour rebondir dessus et c'est vrai c'est
qu'avec les 100 euros de remise qu'on a
là et bien en fait on est à moins de
1000 euros sur un smartphone qui
explique tout à fait hier qu'on est dans
la pop l'innovation sera un smartphone
qui se plie et on touche à moins de 1000
euros
le chef n'a quoi tu veux tu le touches
effectivement haché chez fnac darty à
moins de 1000 euros j'ai un symbole mais
en fait ce qui est fou là-dedans c'est
le symbole c'est à dire qu'en fait tu es
sur un produit d'exception alors après
on adhère on avait repeint tout un
chacun pourra aimer ou ne pas aimer ça
c'est une question très personnelle ce
qui est sûr c'est quand on voit déjà
qu'on est un un prix qui est un petit
peu plus de 1000 euros on dit déjà sont
un peu énervés et quand on passe le
palier psychologique des 1000 euros
alors sur une offre courte on se parlait
d'une oeuvre qui va jusqu'au 15
septembre moins d'un moins de 1000 euros
c'est pareil c'est le prix d'accès le
prix de lancement d'un galaxy s 21 plus
par exemple ça faisait sens pour nous
dans une dans un souci évidemment de
démocratisation de ces produits est
et de révolution des usages parce qu'on
est persuadé chez samsung que les usages
sont vraiment changeant est vrai et
deviennent vraiment apporter des choses
hyper sympa pour les pour les
utilisateurs ça faisait sens bien sûr
d'avoir une positionnement prix qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient plus cohérent et
plus en phase aussi avec avec avec nos
smartphones haut de gamme que tu peux
retrouver aujourd'hui chez samsung sur
de la famille s par exemple alors pour
récapituler un peu parce qu'on a quand
même vu pas mal de choses mais la notion
d'écosystème on voit qu'elle est forte
et qu'elle continue à être présente et
samsung est toujours plus alors après
vous choisissez votre porte d'entrée la
porte d'entrée c'est le smartphone donc
vous pouvez être sûr de la gamme s est
évidemment là on vient de parler de
productivité avec cette folle de 3 a
fait onze ya parlé on vient se parler je
je paye un peu on vient se parler de la
style avec le z flip 3 on vient se
parler effectivement et bien j'ai ma
montre je veux me balader j'ai longé plg
tous facilement la soul doit tout est
très très simple avec cette sorte
d'écosystème beaucoup plus
d'applications niveau de maman de
connecter et la santé et la santé et la
santé avant tout absolument c'est
l'heure de l'apéro on peut y aller voilà
ça permet de rejoindre justement sur les
olives la petite couleur et livres qu'on
a là donc voyez il ya une vraie
cohérence
ça c'est hyper canon donc des produits
qui sont très sympas alors moi je les
teste depuis un petit moment donc mais
montes va bientôt finir par arriver
complètement surtout les premiers sur la
montre notamment sur les écouteurs donc
ça s'annonce vraiment très très sympa un
très joli écosystème qui se développe et
c'est très chouette de voir des produits
de qualité très atypique comme ça très
peur tout achat et mettrait tout intérêt
et puis des produits sur lesquels on est
vraiment venu travailler la robustesse
de manière générale pour apporter des
garanties aux utilisateurs sur la part
sur le sur l'égal accès de philippe iii
aussi sur dur les usages sur le design
général avec cet écran qui est plus
grand à l'arrière enfin une fois le
smartphone fermé qui permet de faire
davantage de choses et tu le disait très
justement la productivité avec la prise
en charge du spn c'était une première
sur un smartphone c'est une première sur
un smartphone pliable c'était une
requête de nos aficionados des
utilisateurs de galaxies de folle de 2
donc on est venu remplir remplir le
contrat pour pour satisfaire au mieux
tous les hits les potentiels et futurs
utilisateurs de galaxies trip 3 ou de
galaxies des trolls de troy j'ai posé
une question avec l'étude pourra pas
répondre puisqu'elle l'a posée quand on
voit ces évolutions qui sont fortes et
qu'on voit ce qu'on arrive à faire
aujourd'hui c'est quoi la prochaine
évolution
j'aimerais que je ne peux pas de réponse
je vous invite à continuer de suivre les
actualités de samsung pour voir ce qu'on
est capable de faire sur sur sur les
années à venir sur les mois à venir et
sur les années à venir puisque ça va
très très vite quand on regarde les déjà
les progrès qui ont été faits entre la
première génération galaxie fold la
génération de l'an dernier et celle ci
il ya un fossé monstrueux qui c'est qui
a été franchie donc on est on est on est
très content et on a hâte de voir ce qui
pourra ce qui pourra venir sur ce qui
pourra survenir sur les sur les mois et
années à venir on suivra ce alors bien
évidemment vous avez des offres
n'oubliez pas sur le site de la fnac.com
samsung 50 sur les mondes connectés
watch quatre wild cat classique 50 euros
de remise c'est jusqu'au 12 septembre et
vous avez samsung s'en soit sur le z
flip 3 est folle de 3 vous avez 100
euros de remise et jusqu'au 15 septembre
vous savez tous merci beaucoup merci à
toi aurélien très heureux d'avoir fait
ce rallye avec toi je vais carrément
donc voilà on a très bien c'est comme ça
merci à vous d'avoir été présent bien
évidemment son site de la fnac pour nous
sied bien évidemment également sans la
chaîne youtube merci à tous et à toutes
c'est pas hyper évident de pouvoir
répondre à vos commentaires j'ai j'ai
voyez passer mais je vous cache pas
comme ça c'est pas très très très simple
je vous aime je ne vous ai pas oublié
sachez le vous êtes dans mon coeur
toujours pour toujours voilà merci
julien mercier relais merci à tout le
monde et à très bientôt sur ceux des
bijoux de l'amour et prenez soin de vous
bideau talus
[Musique]